[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance
I am confident now even more so than I
have been throughout the last year that
this nightmare presidency of Donald John
Trump will end prematurely and end soon
and I am thus also confident that this
is the correct moment to end this series
of commentaries the important stuff
first there are seven routes in front of
Trump each inevitably ends in his
impeachment or resignation the first the
likeliest became a thousand times more
likely with the Thanksgiving news of a
possible deal between robert muller and
general michael Flynn
as I reported here as long ago as April
4th the most specifically qualified
expert alive on the subject of
prosecuting a president my friend the
Nixon White House Counsel John Dean put
it to me very simply Muller is not
shooting down Muller does not make a
deal with Flynn to get Paul Manafort he
does not make a deal with Flynn to get
Jared Kushner he does not make a deal
with Flynn to get chunk jr. Muller makes
a deal with Flynn to get Donald Trump
period the Flynn deal report suggests
Muller has completely assembled the
backbone of his case and is now just
hanging the meat from it and just as
importantly if Flynn has merely
considered a deal from Muller it almost
necessarily means Flynn either doesn't
believe he would get a pardon from Trump
or that Muller as I've also reported
here has succeeded in finding a way
around
Trump's pardon power and either of these
near certainties spell Trump's doom so
that's the most obvious of the seven
ways for Trump to go now Muller really
will get him on Russia it will be ugly
and it will tear this country nearly
apart but it will be necessary the
second way is as I have also repeatedly
suggested here that Muller doesn't
really need to prove anything about
Trump and Russian sabotage of the
election there seems to be so much
obstruction of justice from the firing
of James Comey to the lies about Trump
Jr's meetings with the Russians that
it's hard to pick out a key player in
the Trump inner circle who could not be
guilty of it Trump could be impeached on
just obstruction of justice and a few
lesser charges Nick
it was about to me or there is a third
way we could be spared the trauma of a
Russia impeachment or an obstruction of
justice impeachment as we were spared it
with Nixon if Trump is smart or just
sufficiently scared enough and he
resigns or if he isn't those around him
who could still sell themselves by
selling him out will force him to resign
a modified version of this of course is
the fourth possible outcome but even if
Muller is months away from his day new
mom the Republicans will impeach or
remove Trump by spring purely to save
their own asses the state elections in
Virginia and Oklahoma
earlier this month show what could face
Republican incumbents nationwide next
November not only were Democratic
victories overwhelming but half of them
were little morality plays the 26 year
old lesbian beats the Republican in the
district Trump won by nearly 40 points a
year ago the transgendered candidate in
Virginia beats the guy who wrote an anti
equality bathroom bill the boyfriend of
a news reporter shot to death on camera
beats the Republican Pro NRA candidate
I'll say it again Richard Nixon was not
forced out of office by Democrats not
really even by Watergate Democrats
controlled the Senate and the house
every day Richard Nixon was president
they could have impeached him at any
point he resigned when the leading
Republicans went into the White House
and told him that not only would he be
impeached and convicted but he would
take all of them down with him and they
were not going to let him do that so
that's the fourth way out Trump becomes
more of an albatross to Republicans and
more importantly more of a rallying cry
to Democrats and the Republicans remove
him before the midterms and then
boastfully run for re-election on having
removed him the fifth end game is the
same thing only faster the Republicans
around him pull off that palace coup
that is perfectly legal under the 25th
amendment and Mike Pence and Paul Ryan
and Mitch McConnell eject Trump by
simply stating he is unfit and getting
their majorities to agree he's unfit and
if you don't think Pence and Ryan and
McConnell would do that you didn't see
Trump's crazy tweet about the man of
a year award or this thing in front of
the Native Americans on Monday and you
don't know pence and Ryan and McConnell
the sixth means by which Trump leaves
early is of course that if the
Republicans don't impeach Trump before
the midterms the Democrats will be able
to after the midterms if Virginia and
New Jersey and Oklahoma are indicators
the Democrats could take the house and
might need as few as 25 vulnerable
Republicans in the Senate to vote guilty
to remove Trump from office but now
there is a seventh new path to
destruction for Trump and it is bubbled
up from the sewer of his life recently
and even with how Teflon he has been on
this particular subject it seems hard to
believe the dam won't break his sexual
conduct as not one snowball but a
decade's worth of them have come down
that hill wiping out all the sleaze bags
and embolden and empowering the victims
it seems impossible to believe that some
claimant somewhere does not have
tangible evidence against Trump and that
they won't say to hell with it
and break one of those non-disclosure
agreements and Trump will suddenly be
envying Harvey Weinstein Trump himself
inadvertently has hinted at this the New
York Times buried the lead on this over
the weekend but it reported that earlier
this year Trump told a senator that the
Access Hollywood [ __ ] grabber tape was
a fake and he has said the same thing
again recently to a White House staffer
he's obviously trying to work the refs
of public opinion in advance for
whatever is coming next from a woman
here or from Russia so I don't see any
way out for Trump seven freight trains
rushing at him he might avoid a few he
might avoid six of them he's not going
to dance his way out from under all
seven and we I think should try to put
ourselves in the mindset of those
Americans who knew Richard Nixon with
guilty as hell after John Dean finished
testifying on June 27th 1973 but we're
all left wondering if there would ever
be a way to prove it and were left
listening to a majority of the country
saying Dean was lying and left watching
nearly the entirety of the gullible
news media is saying this was nonsense
why would a president even one as crazy
as Nixon ever do this and more
importantly even if he were somehow
guilty how would he ever be dumb enough
to leave any evidence of his guilt and
16 days later it turned out virtually
everything in the Oval Office had been
taped and the ballgame was over
even though it would last another 13
months well this ball game is also over
and I don't think it's gonna last
another 13 months and so this series is
over this was intended as something
temporary a two-month project by
somebody who had given up politics and
instead it became 187 commentaries and
around 225,000 words and something
approaching 400 million views and I am
proud of it and I repudiate none of it
and it has been my privilege to do it
and I'm especially proud to have done
these videos for free and for charity
but frankly I have not enjoyed one
minute of it as I'm certain it has also
been for you for me it has been
unadulterated pain and revulsion and
horror the process has become nearly
24/7 and I've said so much that I can
and have recycled old commentaries from
months ago and they have been fully
applicable to breaking news we've come
full-circle to such a complete degree
that on Sunday Trump tweeted a complaint
about quote Russia Russia Russia the
title of the 46th episode of the
resistance from last March 14th was
quote Russia Russia Russia I've made my
point so now that I think the outcomes
the seven different inevitable outcomes
are unavoidable I'd like to go back and
enjoy some of my life again and I'm
going to no illness no scandal no firing
just I said what I've had to say it was
as obvious as I made it seem I give my
work everything I can so it's not like I
can dial it back and I think even this
dim-witted world of American political
TV reporting which is still calculating
how to get Trump's idiot supporters to
watch their networks and still waiting
for Trump to pivot even it can carry
this the rest of the way so I am
retiring from
commentary in all media venues this is
not to say a bed of roses and
reconciliation awaits us the post Trump
America will be relieved of his
prodigious evil but in its place it will
have Trump as living martyr that
prodigious evil and rank hypocrisy and
immorality of his supporters perhaps a
third of us will not vanish with him and
I'm not sure that the democracy has not
been damaged too much to deal with their
lawless unprincipled rebellion and I do
not see this country's politics truly
healing in the next 30 or 40 years but
at least the bleeding will be staunch
and we will have a chance to alter a
phrase I heard somewhere to make America
America again thank you for all the kind
words and all the support have fun
storming the castle my work here is done
matter of fact so is Trump's resist
remove peace